i i didn't get school meals but like
were your were your school meals good
what did you get waiting at school meals
there's no cafeteria there was a cafe
like what did they serve at the
cafeteria uh the most like luxury thing
ever was uh this is
[ __ ] it was just a chicken two
chicken tenders in a in a broad role
that was literally
that was that [ __ ] cost four dollars
fifty dollars yeah to me you knew the
kids who were eating goods or who were
the kids that could afford a ham and
cheese panini like if it was salmon
cheese paneer yeah yeah you got a
[ __ ] panini dude bro they gave you
more than they just called it bread
that was all we everything everything
was bread for us it was literally just
two [ __ ] microwave chicken tenders in
a hot dog roll and then if you wanted
ketchup or mayonnaise it was available
for you for like 20 cents
oh my god but even then it was like
because so like i never bought anything
at the at our cafeteria just because i
was like i'm not [ __ ]
way too expensive
inflation
because this is where it really came to
hit me yeah cause i remember i used to
have this i was always given the same
amount of money from like the young age
to spend at the cafeteria and i remember
like when i started high school i could
get any of the meals yeah they weren't
amazing meals by the end i literally
couldn't buy any of the meals unless i
like had half a meal the day before and
then saved and then and then yeah like i
think why did you not renegotiate with
your parents
like
like mom dad their mindset was like well
your brother managed completely fine
throughout high school with this much so
why
what are your problems well yeah because
i think in my household like i i got
allowance for doing chores like pokemon
right and you know it was like maybe
like you know 20 bucks max per month
right which you know to a 10 year old is
is a lot of money yeah but at the same
time
you know when your school at age 10 gave
you [ __ ] meat pies for like a dollar
fifty you know and like you know those
like [ __ ] squeezy ketchup packets
yeah those were 20 cents and i was like
dog i'm not paying 20 cents i'm not
paying a literal 100th of my monthly
allowance for a little [ __ ] squirt of
ketchup like i'm not [ __ ] doing that
you guys didn't have pack lunches like i
had i had to have packed lunches for
most of the days yeah so yeah so like
most of my days for me as well was like
pack lunches right because my my mom was
like
i'm not giving you [ __ ] money yeah
expensive because for me like my
allowance would like last the entire
week and then i'd treat myself to the
ham and cheese panini that was that was
that was like the friday meal that was
like
that you did it the smart way i i was
like you know what i could buy that
chicken tenderloin but i could also buy
this yu-gi-oh booster pack as well okay
okay okay
here's what i did right i would uh i'd
get so i get two pounds a day right
which was like i could buy one meal if i
waited like a day and i had something
small yeah um and so i was like but i
actually want
video games instead so i would go into
the town which is like a 20 minute walk
i would go to the it's called home
bargains yeah in the uk it's like a
poundland or whatever yeah i would buy a
family bag of crisps
like 12 packs for a pound yeah and i
would just eat that the whole week
this is awful this is probably why it's
the most british thing i've ever heard
because right a video game back then it
was 30 pounds yeah right right so if i
if i did this for a whole month i got a
new game yeah sure my mom was wondering
where the [ __ ] i got this game from
she didn't even know that i was getting
i was eating chris it's probably an
awful thing to do with my body but i
didn't care i was like 15. i wanted the
video game you see you had so much more
of a stronger willpower than me because
like i could not save money for that
long i could i did if i could i had the
i had the object in mind i was like i
want the new halo game i'm not even no
dude in my head i was like every time i
went to like an electronic store and i
was like oh the new the new mario party
on we is out how much does it cost
eighty dollars oh
i'm like okay i could save up four
months worth of allowance together but
my birthday is also in seven months time
so uh maybe i could just like hint at it
now and then just wait seven months for
me to actually get the game which is
what i did yeah because for me like when
i wanted to buy a video game like i grew
up in like like when i was in school i
was it was like the n64 snares era yeah
and like games back then was like 60
pounds a game yeah yeah yeah um for like
a cartridge was it really yeah yeah it's
like half huh like half yeah like i i
remember when like when like games
started coming out on disks i'm just
like why is it so so much cheaper now
what the hell and the graphics are
better this is what what kind of hacks
are they putting to is like mesh
producing those things yeah yeah yeah
that makes sense
yeah so like back back in those days
like there was no [ __ ] way i can
afford like a cartridge game like the
only times i was getting new games was
like christmas and birthday those were
the two times of the year where i got
games and like i was praying that i
could like i was praying that my parents
bought like the right games every time
yeah i was like mother i have waited an
entire year
if i don't get at least three games i am
going to rage
when i turned like 16 they were like we
want you to have a bit of an allowance
so that you can learn how to manage your
money and i was like oh thanks and i was
just thinking like i've got a lot saved
already though
i was like this is just adding to the
wealth this is how i become basis i
think i think my parents thought the
same way but only after they found out
that i got rejected from my mcdonald's
job so they were like there's no saving
you or your allowance so you don't end
up being a bomb the more i think about
it more i was like yeah i don't know if
i was always going to be
that kind of way with money i don't know
i wonder is it like i do i guess you
have to teach your kid how to learn how
to uh manage money yeah i see videos but
like nobody taught me how to manage
money i just spent it all when i was
like 20 and stuff and i'm like oh you
have to do this
[Music]
shark
a very very very british thing what
christmas reckon i was eating by the way
walkers no
that's too expensive quavers no i think
think cheap
what's a cheap don't look at me man
this is for very british audiences right
now i don't know i just gonna hit you
like a wave this goes oh my [ __ ] god
okay okay i completely forgot that they
even existed i haven't had disco since
like
you're like 12. yeah i was like did what
did i reach double digits for the last
time i had disco i can't [ __ ]
remember like the cheap [ __ ] chips yeah
they were like
weirdly good but there was probably so
much like msg and [ __ ] yeah oh they were
really tasty but they were weirdly like
super cheap like you had all the other
chips but they taste really [ __ ] good
really good
chris review yeah